alright so we're very excited to welcome
you all to the next installment of our
video series created as part of the
course
slaw environment and religion at Yale
University my name is Clara row and I'm
a master's student at the Yale School of
Forestry and environmental studies and
I'm South austere rose and a master's
student in the Divinity School and we're
very pleased to have William Riley with
us today he's a Yale graduate former
director of WWF EPA Administrator under
President George HW Bush co-chair of the
national commission on the BP deepwater
horizon oil spill and offshore drilling
and board member of various well known
corporations and not-for-profits thanks
for joining us today that very pleased
to be you guys too so bill if we could
lead off with it just a question about
how you got into environmentalism maybe
a point of childhood story or just
something that you recall that comes
back that there are two very distinct
memories that I have about that more or
less relate to my interest I think one
is of a farm which my parents owned and
my dad used to say is since he had some
difficulties when I was in college that
that's what puts you through college at
farm so that gave me a special
attachment to it and I used to go there
on from time to time and and ride down
the corn stalks and watch the foxes play
out in the fields which they used to do
in those days and it was full of
wildlife because all of the hedgerows
the middle west nobody here is old
enough to remember that but there was a
time when the farms were typically
bounded by them really as windbreaks
among other things but they were full of
pheasant and grouse and foxes and all
sorts of Twilight and I I really was
attached to that and took that as normal
and then I can remember as a little boy
I think I was four we had a summer
vacation my father was home from the
Army in Sturgeon Bay Wisconsin and I
looked across a water body that you
couldn't see across I never imagined
that there was a lake like that and we
went swimming in it i remember it was
too cold for me but not for my sister
was four years older and then i saw the
ocean the same year because my parents
my father had a
had a romance about the sea and about
travel he worked on ships and he'd
worked on trains he was always in motion
and he very much regretted I think that
he was spending his business career in
central Illinois so far from the ocean
and I caught from him this fascination
of the sea and we used to ride the ferry
to Jamestown from Newport and the
Atlantic destroyer fleet was in there
then and my dad would point out all the
ships and we would take maybe six or
seven rides across we just stay on and
it costs I don't know nickel then send
something like that and I think it just
took and water I was mostly known i
think base pika because we we revisited
the Clean Air Act and and did some sets
and precedents in that area as an air
person but actually water was my passion
and I later after i was in government
founded a firm that invested a little
over three hundred million dollars in
water in developing countries water
sanitation drinking water drip
irrigation beer and butter storage
anything related to water I did and I it
just has been a theme and the reason I
did it what the real passion came from
talking to environment ministers at the
rio conference in 1992 where I headed
the US delegation and several of them at
least five brought up one way or another
the fact that we were involved in what
to them were middle class enthusiasms in
that we were concerned about ozone
depletion upper atmospheric ozone
depletion biodiversity and climate and
several of them without disparaging
those concerns said no one is dying for
those issues in our countries Nigeria
Mexico India Malaysia but they are for
want of clean water or for one of
sanitation and that's the reason I
founded the water fund so that's been
kind of a theme in my in my career and I
think it all started back there with
Lake Michigan and on the farm in Sarah
Gardner Illinois
all right thank you thanks a lot so we
want to take you sort of from the small
to the large and ask you if you could
give us sort of a thermometer reading if
you had to say what is the state of
environmental affairs today what what
have you seen change how do you think
people's actions and consciousness have
changed toward the environment in your
career it's common for environmentalists
to be doomsayers and part of that is
that has been important I think to
animating the movement energizing it
raising this the resources to support it
but I think it's wrong if you look at
the period in which i've been involved
in the environment we have made fabulous
progress there are very few priorities
that we said as a country on which we
have not made very substantial progress
it starts with air and water well then
it goes on to toxic sand hazardous waste
management and safe drinking water the
whole series of statutes that were
passed in the early 70s we have very
indisputable metrics of success we'd not
solve all these problems but go to LA
today if you remember what it was like
30 years ago it's a transformed place
the same is true of the Hudson River and
the Great Lakes the big concern about
Lake Erie when I was in office was
whether we were going to have any fish
in Lake Erie now we've got a lot of fish
yeah you can't eat them I don't want
over here but you know it's a good news
bad news story but it's basically
directionally correct as I used to say
when we hadn't solved a problem but we
were working on it I've recently had
occasion to spend time worrying about
the oceans and policy for for the marine
environment that's not a success story
to the same degree we've never set a
priority for the oceans we don't have
National Ocean policy so it's no
surprise in some ways it isn't it isn't
something that we devoted these same
resources to I am a big believer that
anyone who's involved with the
environmental movement should begin by
recognizing the foundation that we built
and what fabulous things the country has
done with the resources we've had which
have taken a lot of attention sacrifice
court suits contention but that by and
large it worked bill if I could ask you
if I could sort of follow up that
question and say that in preparation in
preparation for your visit we've we've
read quite a bit of your work from the
time that you're in the EPA director of
the EPA to the time working on the BP
oil spill more recently I'm wondering
how do you see your own rhetoric and
methods of advocacy having changed over
time throughout your career well I read
some of the stuff that you all were
looking at and gregg easterbrook was a
fan of mine and he says my jokes felt
planner I've got to talk to Greg about
it Greg by the way is someone who has
written that the environment is one of
the two great success stories of
post-war social policy the other one
being social security I think that what
was the question how your your methods
have changed over time say so your time
in the EPA yeah and the way you speak
and think about things well I've always
been I've always been reasonably
confident of the directions were going
and of the kinds of things we're doing
the environment I had the good fortune
to be there when things were happening
what you really want i've served 2 times
in the government aside from my army
period and the first was the
environmental rally i was hired in the
spring of nineteen seventy just a couple
of weeks before earth day and my first
job was to find five hundred million
dollars in projects that we would cancel
of major dams around the country and i
can remember i was just out of the army
and i called it the corps of engineers
and they sent a brigadier general and a
couple
kernels and a light colonel to hold the
pointer and they were seeking the
language I didn't understand feet per
second and acre feet and all and I was
busily writing it down but I was a white
house so they had to take it very
seriously we found the money
incidentally it often works in public
life you find out later what the money
was about it was it was to find money
for school desegregation and bussing in
the south but we found that money and i
wrote the regulations for environmental
impact assessment which is brand new
statute that international environmental
policy act i wrote but became the
Coastal Zone Management Act I had
written it as a national land use policy
act that failed by one vote in the House
passed the Senate a couple of times and
all of those clean air clean water toxic
substances safe drinking water later in
the decade hazardous waste and waste
management those were charters for
action and very ambitious action so that
it was it was heaven to be alive in that
environment of excitement and really
substantial change in the way we had
previously addressed environmental
problems nature nature conservation I
think what happened in the late 60s was
the conjunction between the community of
people concerned about birds and trees
National Audubon Society National
Wildlife Federation hunters and
fishermen with the public health
community that increasingly was affected
by the epidemiological evidence of
pollutions effect on people and lungs
particulates in the lungs particularly
especially and they came together and
they created a very new phenomenon a new
force and President Nixon when he was
campaigning in 68 is said to have been
astounded to discover that along with
the war in Vietnam and the economy the
environment was in the top three
concerns the American public and that
helped explain why he made it such a
priority those days were days of much
less sophistication about the issue when
I looked at non-governmental
organizations I don't believe
that except for resources for the future
which was not an environmentalist
organization I don't believe there was
an economist in any one of the NGOs it
was a time when most of the statutes did
not have the kind of scientific basis
that that now we would we would expect
them to have all of the research that
went into our acid rain provision there
was a ten-million-dollar was called
napalm national acid precipitation study
at senator Moynihan was sponsoring and
was very proud of that all came with
gradual change and business finally I
think at some point major companies
certainly realized that the support for
Environmental Protection clean air and
clean water particularly was in the mid
80s even through the Arab oil embargo
even through economic downturns it was
constant support and I think the
shrewder business leaders decided this
is here to stay we need to get involved
in a way we didn't when we just opposed
these laws and help make them work and I
think the best of our of our corporate
citizens have done that I think you've
you've hinted at a few transitions that
we've talked about in class as well one
being sort of the shift from command and
control towards market mechanisms and
the other being you know real bipartisan
support and and the idea that everyone
cared about the environment to
increasing polarization of environmental
issues and I wonder whether you agree
with that you know that characteristic
of characteristic of shifts but also
whether you think they're they're
related in any way when we're thinking
about how people have changed in terms
of the way they're dealing with
environmental issues I was involved a
few years ago I think almost well almost
ten years ago in the establishment of a
new instituted Duke and we commissioned
some polling and it turned out that
there were two perceptions that were a
break on new initiatives in the
environment one was the sense that we'd
solve the problems the principal obvious
visible problems and the other was that
regulation cost jobs and cost money
those perceptions are out there and it's
difficult to credit them that much
because we had a budget director in the
bush administration they used to say
that the Clean Air Act was going to
cause a depression in the 1990s we all
saw what happened the economy in the
1990s it's a lot cleaner do it was you
cannot make that argument I don't think
respectively the sense that Republicans
participated in all that was so
important in the beginning senator
Chafee though several senators and from
New England states particularly played a
key role with senators muskie and
Jackson Democrats on collaborating in
clean air act and the Clean Water Act
particularly that major charters that
continued into the early 80s we had a
bit of a backlash a deregulatory
backlash in the early Reagan
administration and some of you may know
the history of secretary wat at the
Interior Department and burford miss
burford at the EPA and and yet the take
on their experience which only lasted
about two years was that was a big
mistake to claim to roll back those
fundamental commitments so we got in a
situation where at the moment it's
difficult I think for the critics of
environmentalism and environmental
legislation regulation to roll them back
effectively but it's relatively easy for
them to prevent new initiatives or
strengthening and we're having very
difficult time on the climate issue
that's his special issue that seems to
have attracted the lightning in a way
that nothing really else does and I've
thought a lot about why it is that
Senator McCain could run on a platform
and actually have been the sponsor of
McCain Lieberman which was cap and trade
bill I was told frankly by the third
ranking member of the house that if who
is a rhodes scholar as PhD in british
history that if he were to have
supported cap-and-trade he would have
been wisely advised not even to run in
his primary
because of concerns that have angelica's
have about about climate change and
about carbon regulation well we have
those constituency issues since not just
rich donors the Koch brothers who are
preventing us from addressing this
question it's more fundamental than that
I am reasonably confident that at some
point we're going to have a breakout as
Senator Whitehouse has put it of of a
group of Republicans who will all make
for the make for the green hills of
climate regulation together otherwise
they're going to get picked off one by
one and I think that started to happen
last month when 15 senators 15
Republican senators voted and a
resolution that there is global warming
climate change occurring humans are
contributing into it five of them said
significantly tanta didn't go that
apparently the distinction is that if
you said significantly you got to
support regulation I've been told so I'm
I'm reasonably confident that we're
going to see a change and i'm the
product myself of President to was vice
president under Reagan after all and who
made himself the environmental candidate
used the issue very effectively in the
summer of nineteen eighty eight it
happened to be an unusual summer was
very hot we were always own alerts all
across the country and there was a
hazardous waste medical waste washing up
on the beaches of New Jersey and Long
Island he used that very effectively in
the country turned I used to deal with a
lot of people in the Congress even the
administration who didn't get it who
didn't see this as a issue for
Republicans but Bush did and exploited
it very effectively and used it to give
us leadership and a lot of the things
that we accomplished on wetlands and air
and whole range of subjects to follow up
on on that point and ask so you're
talking about a shift from more
environmental concern to less and you
tribute this to at least in part
concerns of Evangelicals United States
and denial of climate change but that
Republicans are starting to to come back
to these concerns what do you attribute
that return to these concerns too and is
it is it that you know evangelicals are
coming around so real Pope you know
these these Republican senators say
don't have as much to worry about or is
there a kind of split going on what do
tribute yeah I used to know Richard
sighs it was the political director for
the oven jab national 11 Jellicle
Association and he would explain the
concerns that evangelicals had about the
about irrigating to humans control of
the Earth's climate something so
fundamental which was considered
overstretch and untrue and I'm not that
informed about any of that and I'm not
aware of any movement on the part of em
angelicus what I would assume is
happening is that whereas when i served
in office the climate issue was largely
a function of modeling we had the models
and we had reports two of them at least
from the National Academy of Sciences
they've predicted climate change we
didn't have many effects we could point
to well now you've got effects
everywhere I mean you've got all sorts
of of drought and flood and glacial
melting and the Arctic melting incidents
that have been predicted by the models
but now they're occurring I mean it's
indisputable and Miami Beach I was just
noticing that senator Rubio has just
declared for the presidency he said some
things about climate which for florida
senator i found very difficulty the sub
these South Florida politicians are now
dealing with sea level rise which is
very disruptive and they're having to
put in all sorts of pipes of pumps to
make sure that the water when it backs
up after a severe storm is pushed back
into the sea well that's just one of the
kind of experiences that we're going to
see a lot more of in the years ahead and
I think given the relative consensus and
it's really a vast preponderance of
scientific opinion that climate change
is happening and it's going to continue
nobody's oblivious to it and I have
heard of one congressman tell me that
they're at least 100 Republicans in the
House who fully get it and understand it
but constituencies have kept them from
going public with it I think that will
change I think our politics is very
responsive to to news to changes to
perceptions on the part of the public to
cultural transitions we have a pretty
fluid system and largely I think over
time responsive system so I suspect that
will change and that gradually have been
Jellico's and others will agree whether
or not humans are causing the change
that it is in fact occurring I was very
impressed that in 1996 Mayor Daley no
reputed tree hugger him in Chicago
convened the leaders of several
scientists from several of the great
universities in Chicago and they
formulated the scientific basis for what
has become the Chicago climate action
plan well that plan assumed a certain
decline in the level of Lake Michigan it
assumed temperatures in the 95 plus area
for 45 days of the year the average last
century was 15 it assumed that waterfall
rainfall will be much more like
California's at california continues to
get any water that is that it falls
between November and April and then it
doesn't you don't see it rain again they
change the tree species that they plant
in the parks they plant 2200 trees a
year and no longer Illinois ash which is
the state tree or Norway spruce or maple
they just won't make it they're planning
Alabama gum and they've got permeable
pavement they've invented whole range of
things and the interesting thing to me
about this is there was no ideology
there was no attempt to blame anybody
for this it just looks like it's in our
future and this is a prudent mayor and
imprudent leadership and that's what
they did Bloomberg did something very
similar you didn't hear a lot of
arguments and his you hear them now from
him about the necessity to change our
ideological outlook on client
except scientific opinion but mostly he
changed the fuels that were in use and
the insulation standards and whole range
of other things he said incidentally
something that I quite loved his
planning advisor reported in his book
that Mayor Bloomberg looked at the city
of New York and he saw six boroughs the
five boroughs we know and the waterfront
and proceeded to invest in it make the
most of its recreational advantages
anyway I I think it's possible to
address these issues and adapt to them
prudently to begin to accommodate what
appears to be an inevitable future and
to do so without spending a lot of time
casting blame on humanity if that's if
that's politically expedient I wonder if
you're surprised by how long it's taken
for this action to come and especially
thinking about action on the
international level with the cop coming
up in Paris I wonder what you think is
at stake in terms of that international
agreement is it is that critical to
having a climate solution or as the city
by city basis as we're starting to see
in the u.s. is not more going to it's a
good question the interesting thing to
me when I first saw the terms of the cop
in Paris are that they've set the bar
pretty low they really a few if you
understand that have said each of the
countries present what it is you're
going to do and we're going to bless you
we're going to say bravo you know I was
discouraged by that and yet I began to
think about I serve on the board have
served on the board of the Packard
Foundation which is provided 500 billion
dollars over five years and just
recently renewed their support for
climate work in China and other places
Hewlett Foundation same thing matched it
and I remember when waxman-markey went
down to defeat the climate bill in the
United States in a Congress and we had
no progress made seriously at
Copenhagen the reaction among Packard
women the members of the family on the
board is well there's so many good
things we can do with our resources we
had the impression that this was going
to be a winning ticket we're going to
make some progress it doesn't appear
that we are and I think that kind of
sense of failure began to permeate the
conversations about climate and there
was a sense for a while that well we
were going to get anywhere with this and
maybe it wasn't worth the candle in
terms of certainly philanthropy there's
so many things that you can do it that
you have prospect of winning on with
that in mind I've sort of thought that
maybe it makes sense maybe it makes
sense if we get reasonably good
commitments from the United States and
we do what's happening on 111 d is it's
called the carbon regulation for
existing power plants is terrific EPA is
carrying an awfully big load and the
Clean Air Act I can tell you was not
designed to bury nevertheless it's what
we have and it happens to be working and
if you take that as forty percent of the
of the carbon monoxide that comes from
power plants electrical generating
facilities and then you add to it the 54
and a half mile per gallon automobile
fuel efficiency standard that was worked
out with the auto industry by the
administration that alone by the way the
latter is going to be responsible for a
reduction in about of about two million
little more than two million barrels of
oil a day in the United States it's
fabulous terrific progress so for those
especially in the rest of the world who
look at the United States and think
we're doing nothing well the Congress
manages to convince everybody about and
they quite effective at it but in truth
those two items if we can maintain both
of them and obviously this is going to
depend on the next president because
we're not going to complete carbon
regulation in this in this president's
term it will have to be it doesn't even
come out yet but it will have to be
litigated and it will take a long time
to litigate it and finally to get
something happening that makes a
difference in the climate but we're on
the right track it's directionally
correct can I jump in with with one
question so thinking about solutions I'm
wondering what we can learn from the
Montreal Protocol which you know it's
touted as this very successful
international protocol to address ozone
and and in that case we saw big
companies like DuPont actually playing a
really important role in making that
happen partly because they could benefit
from this substitute for CFCs and I
wonder whether you see a similar role in
that solution making for companies
especially those involved in fossil fuel
production when we think about climate
change or whether that is kind of a
fundamentally different issue than ozone
and there's not that same role to be
played climate is a much more
complicated issue than upper atmospheric
ozone depletion it wasn't so simple for
DuPont either DuPont gave up an 800
million dollar revenue item in CFCs
which they had invented if you know
these people I served on the dupe on
board as chairman the environmental
policy it was their baby as their
children these things it's like nylon
and Kevlar that's good it wasn't so easy
but they did decide that they were
implicated and they made a constructive
in public regarding mood they then did
something else it turned out to be very
important I remember going to mrs.
Thatcher's conference on over
atmospheric ozone and she was a chemist
at Cambridge by the way she understood
the issues and I walked over to the
minister from China and I said do you
dispute the science we had just shown
NASA's ozone hole video and he said well
we find it awfully convenient that these
products that are so useful to us now
and that you have substitutes for are to
be banned no he said we'll have to find
I find out whether the National Academy
of Sciences of China supports this
interpretation but at that time there
were some 300 million new refrigerators
planned to be built over the next 10
years in China 300 billion they were all
going to contain CFCs and I asked DuPont
to send people to explain to them that
the substitutes could cost no more than
a dollar per refrigerator and they did
and that was effective but it would have
blown us all the way it really did show
you how a problem like that if it's
not addressed internationally you're not
going to get anywhere the climate issue
is more complicated it's it's
complicated by a number of things one of
which is that fossil fuels are so useful
I mean what else will drive a gallon
will drive a two-and-a-half tonne car 20
miles I mean it's it's just hard too
hard to come up with anything as
efficient we are going to get there I
think and the natural gas revolution is
getting us there I mean when you talk
about corporations it's it's useful to
look at the commitments that President
Obama made to get a seventeen percent
reduction by 2020 in our greenhouse
gases we're about halfway there we're
there because the oil and gas industry
because they figured out how to get gas
but more important the liquids
co-located with them cheaply and
plentifully to use that tells you
something I think very important and
it's relevant to divestiture movement be
careful be careful not to reduce the
capital expenditures or capabilities of
these companies it's very likely I
served on the board of one and I
remember they got very excited about to
something called general compression of
Boston company that was working in Texas
to try to compress compress sub
basically to store power to store energy
and they have the resources to expend
and when the time comes I think they
will probably be important to the
solutions just as they're now major part
of the problem in terms of getting the
conversion I've been very impressed at
how fast renewables have come on some
years ago I paid eight dollars and a
half per kilowatt for solar panels at a
place that I have in Sonoma County
California and this year put on 12 more
for four dollars that's six or eight
years cut it in half that's that's where
things are going and I think that's
going to make it more straight forward
over time people are making money
on renewables I've just watched a
company in Texas make a commitment for
220 megawatts of solar power utility
grade solar now that hasn't been
happening before it's happened in a few
places but utility grade Solar will
transform especially in conjunction with
carbon regulation the whole situation
visa vco2 I'm reasonably confident
that's going to happen the oil price is
not helpful there $50 oil price is going
to make it more difficult natural gases
is so cheap that finally making the
conversion out of natural gas might be
problematic and more so than we then we
would like on the other hand let's keep
our eye on the ball natural gas is
displacing coal that is very much to be
desired that is a good consequence for
Public Policy will face the next problem
of converting from gas when it's time
but meanwhile let's move coal out of the
system bill I read recently that well
natural gas is certainly a cleaner
fossil fuel than some others the way
that it's extracted through fracking is
it releases so much methane it
contaminates so much water it makes so
much you know it it kills the water as
as I said there are so many problems
with the way that way that it's done
which are difficult to avoid because
it's a spreading method I wanted to
bring that up but then also with
dimension of China I also read recently
that roughly half of the pollution that
China creates is for is industry to
export things to the Western world so
it's almost as though we have exported
our pollution but continued the same
consumption patterns and so I think that
that does speak to the complexity of the
climate change issue which you've
pointed out but it's it's hard for me to
see in that way that progress is really
being made well it's true it's true that
our consumption is powering a lot of the
Chinese
contamination and they are quick to tell
you that if you meet with them which I
do regularly that basically we cause the
large accumulation of upper atmospheric
co2 and methane and our consumption is
now being underwritten by them to
tremendous economic advantage that on
their part but nevertheless that's we
have exported exported it the only thing
I would say about that is that China has
just had a year in which they have not
increased their coke and coal
consumption as a first at the same time
as they had a seven percent gdp increase
this is really directionally correct
this is a big deal and then the world of
course is just experienced a year in
which greenhouse gases didn't increase
on the fracking issue we have been
tracking for quite some time natural gas
wells what's really novel about the
current system is that is the
directional multi-directional way that
we can pull up these resources my
impression is that the major problems
with contamination of surface water
certainly has occurred as a consequence
of people who had very little
experienced with the technology
certainly the major oil companies
consider that what happened in
Pennsylvania was shocking and
inexcusable where the casements were
breaking casements don't break and
that's just not it doesn't happen if
you've got a reasonably efficient
operator and most of the big companies
know how to do it as for the methane
releases those look like they're
anywhere from less than 1 to four
percent and one of the marvelous things
that happened as i was asked earlier
today about the future of ngos and
whether there's a career there we well
it's a major NGO Environmental Defense
Fund that's set out to develop the
appropriate regulations to first of all
get a fix on how big the problem is and
then to come up with the appropriate
regulatory approach that will limit the
methane releases which ought not to be
that hard because its product after all
it's money it's the commodity
so I think that's a completely
manageable problem and as far as the
water contamination is concerned that is
not happening in most of the states with
the with the experience that of oil and
gas Texas Oklahoma Nebraska what is
happening is the industrialization of a
lot of previously bucolic and
undeveloped areas that is a consequence
of the technology it's the
industrialization of parts of the
countryside and no doubt that they're
going to be winners and losers in such a
system but I wouldn't lose sight of the
fact that for the country as a whole
it's really changed our energy economy
it's given us the capacity to move
beyond coal fired power and move to gas
right away and that's hot that's
happening something like a third of
coal-fired power has already been
affected that's profoundly to be desired
the same advantages have occurred to a
whole range of industries thinks of
chemicals or Luminum they are in a much
better competitive situation as a
consequence of the cheap gas so it's
doing good things for the economy by and
large is doing good things for the
environment and it's it's giving us the
possibility of displacing coal so I
imagine that we could keep going
industry by industry and have a really
productive conversation about this but I
wonder if in the interest of time we can
step back for a moment and think about
kind of the larger systems driving this
and one of the things that comes up a
lot in forestry school classes and I
know in other places as well as sort of
an ongoing and perhaps growing debate
over whether capitalism can successfully
address environmental problems and I
think you know authors like Naomi Klein
and gas Beth argue that capitalism is
sort of a fundamental fundamentally
misaligned with environmental goals and
you know based on my reading of your
work I think you show that market
mechanisms can work in some and some
instances and I wonder if you think or
if you can tell us a bit more about how
you think they work and whether there
are places when they don't work well
I've always been fascinated by the fact
that the materiality of
value has been has been decreasing that
is that it's taken we're getting a lot
more high-value low material product as
civilization develops and evolves we're
we're growing so fast that it's
discounting that effect but that is
what's been happening and that's
certainly to be desired I think
capitalism will work toward more
efficient use of resources and
commodities but whether it will do it
fast enough to accommodate the growth I
really don't know I with respect to the
pollution rights trading and things of
that sort there's no doubt that it
proved a vastly more efficient approach
to reducing sulfur dioxides than any
other choice we might have made and I
look back in my own agency predicted
that would cost between 600 and 800
dollars a ton to get sulfur dioxides out
of the utility emissions the electric
utility industry which should know more
about it than we did if estimated 1,300
to $1,500 a ton well it came in under
well under 200 it was much much more
efficient than we anticipated and I
think there are analogies in other areas
I don't think you can get there though
simply that way when you finally are
going to have to get a 50 or even an
eighty percent reduction in greenhouse
gases I think we're going to need very
specific regulations that impel a
transition to non-fossil fuels and I
think in a lot of places that's going to
be that's going to be difficult I think
to the extent that we target resource
development which to this some extent
this administration has tried to do in
the energy area to promote renewables
alternatives so you really have the
alternatives I think that's very
important it's pretty clear that most
people most economies will not easily
give up the conveniences associated with
high fossil fuel development and that's
going to need serious regulation now
whether that's capitalistic I mean I
think you within a capitalistic
environment if trying
generally accommodate consumer demands
in a more benign way with less impact on
the environment I think all of that is
potentially possible but I suspect it's
going to take strong regulation to get
there so you imagine governance
structures as a very important way to
overlay yes on the system yes someone
had to say finally CFCs are just not
permissible any longer and even
recognizing that they were so useful and
they were particularly useful in the
developing world they hired at they had
a harder time with the replacement they
got resources developed world stepped
forward and provided those funds but
that was not an easy transition and this
one is likely to be a more complex one
yeah did you want to jump in yeah you
know Bill I noticed that you attribute
or you make the statement that it will
it's difficult to make people change
their habits that if you're in a in the
habit of high consumption that's going
to be you know and which depends upon
fossil fuel use it's going to be
difficult to rehabilitate of that which
I'm sure is true but it I wonder if it
this is more an issue of the habits of
consumption or if they have to do with
the markets that really thrive on that
consumption and encourage it I'm
thinking a last Monday ExxonMobil issued
two reports right which were a response
to shareholders about a resolution that
demand at that demanded that they
disclose their carbon risk and talk
about how they plan to deal with the
fact that they another oil giants may
have many many times more carbon in
their collective reserves than
scientists say we can safely burn from
from there one of these reports that I
quote based on this analysis says
ExxonMobil we are confident that none of
our hybrid hydrocarbon reserves aren't
are now or will become stranded so what
can the environmental world do with this
perspective coming from
these from these sort of corporate
giants who thrive on fossil fuel
extraction and consumption some of you
may remember shaky Imani who was the
minister of oil of Saudi Arabia who
famously quoted as saying the Stone Age
did not end because we ran out of stones
the oil industry the oil age won't end
because we run out of oil I mean there
will be stranded assets I see no
alternative to it unless we figure out a
way to capture the carbon and sequester
it which thus far we have not found an
economical way to do at scale if that
does not happen but some of these
companies will have a tremendous impetus
and interest in making it happen but if
it does not happen I see no alternative
to stranding those assets and would not
consider it in terms of economic history
unprecedented if it turns out that we've
got many more benign possibilities that
have come on as competitors I had a tour
around the Tesla plant from elon musk
not too long ago any of you seen that
car would love to have one really
beautiful car we're going to see those
come on I don't think we're going to see
it come on as fast as we might have this
is another area where low price gas
gasoline consequence of the oil price
now will possibly delay the introduction
but I think the future is pretty good
for such things for electric vehicles
one has to hope that the power plants
that are after all providing the
electricity are themselves not
coal-fired power many of them still are
but I'm reasonably confident that that
ExxonMobil is wrong about that they the
transitions is it's they're very
sophisticated that the exxonmobil study
particularly as it comes out every year
and in my own firm in the private equity
firm tpg in San Francisco we've looked
closely at their scenarios versus the
scenario of our alternative energy fund
and it's difficult to dispute them and
their projections in the near term but
as you get farther out and
the science is more compelling and as
the politics begins to reflect not just
the science but the real impact of
climate change of on people I think
you're going to see a transformation and
sorry just less less little faux up on
that are you saying that we're going to
see a trans transformation coming from
the habits side of the consumer or is
that going to be more on regulation I
think it's I think it would be a mixture
but I think that the the coincidence of
increasing public concern individual
ethical concern together with the
alternatives that are less destructive
in the environment that are more benign
non-fossil fuel alternatives will change
the culture so we've we've kept things
sort of to the political economic realm
I think not quite intentionally but this
is a class where we're trying to examine
serve the intersection of religion law
and environment and so I'm curious about
you know especially in a democracy the
ways in which we try to listen to
people's contradicting values at times
and when those values may or may not
align with environmental goals how we
integrate those in a way that moves
towards a future that seems like the
environmentally sustainable future so I
and I guess it's a really a question
about the balance of sort of process in
the democratic process and the end goal
of an environmentally sustainable future
my sense is that the religious community
has had very little impact on our
thinking about something like climate I
look back on my own history and shortly
after I became an EPA Administrator I
was invited to a meeting of several
cardinals that President Bush was having
I remember he greeted my wife and me at
the elevator and he said be quick to put
out your hand they kind of all look
alike to me and I got inside and
Cardinal law who was a very formidable
figure the Archbishop of Boston
discovered who I was and he lit into me
about my asbestos rules and I started to
say to him oh we don't regulate his
bestest he's no no you don't do that you
just require that we do an audit
well he said we find there's asbestos in
the school let me tell you what happens
the parents say no way I want my
children in that school the bishop goes
to the banker the banker says love to
lend money to you Bishop but we never
lend money on his bestest containing
building well anyway I heard that I was
a little stung I hadn't been lobbied
before I was brand-new at EPA I thought
well actually I've got some things I'd
like to get off my chest so I went over
to there I went over to the Cardinal
Archbishop of Chicago Cardle burnin and
I said you know you've been associated
with marvelous pastoral statements on
nuclear war on poverty never said one
word about the environment and I've been
going to mass for 40 years I've never
heard it once mentioned from the pulpit
he said interesting he said I've kept
environment out of our pastoral thinking
we might want to do that someday do you
have an idea of what we should say I see
yes I do and I said look at what the
bishop said in Germany Mexico
Philippines have said well a few weeks
went by maybe more than that I got
invited to speak to the Social Welfare
Committee of the bishops and I popped
off on my views and it seems so
self-evident that a theology of
incarnation includes nature in the hole
certainly the Catholic tradition which
is a very sacramental tradition looks as
at so much as sacred with plenty of
biblical support for that that outlook
should have resulted in a ended joining
together of environmental or in concern
and sympathy that and that it hasn't and
any rate some time went by and I didn't
see anything from them so I asked to see
the Pope word came back well the Pope
doesn't see ministers few weeks later I
got invitation to see the Holy Father
and was told that someone in the
hierarchy had said this is not an
ordinary minister so I went off and I I
was going to tell the Pope what to do I
was going to tell him to order the
American bishops to issue a pastoral and
I was told by Monsignor dire mood Martin
is now Archbishop of Dublin it doesn't
work that way he would never do it I
said well I'm going to tell him that he
should have a statement he said well
that you can do and every we didn't we
didn't talked about it
and and yet I still to this day that the
bishops the United States issued a very
good statement superb statement on this
and in a very modest way saying that
they were admittedly engaging the issue
largely for the first time I mean given
that the two great saints of the Western
and conservation tradition Benedict and
Francis are both in a Christian saints
and revered for for their sanctity how
come how come this didn't translate into
an ethic that's a little more obviously
compelling and communicated better
communicated than it is but it isn't and
I don't I think that's generally true
that the religious community has has not
integrated they're thinking about the
sanctity of the earth and what
theologically means to protect it or to
despoil it with their conventional
ethical concerns and obligations bill
I'd like to ask you one last question on
that point actually before we wrap up
which is that in the Bible we have San
Genesis 1 the Dominion model of you know
mankind and nature Genesis 2 more of a
stewardship model and a third model
gaining prominence and largely due to
thinkers like Thomas berry from whom our
classes title community of subjects
comes sees mankind as primarily part of
nature assuming that you don't prescribe
as much the Dominion model I assuming
that could be wrong do you see humans
more as stewards of the environment or
as parts of it wow thank you going
beyond me here
it's very hard for me to say that I
wouldn't accept either one I think the
reality that is unique to our century is
we have a dominion over nature the like
of which humankind never had before my
understanding from friends in the of
angelical world is that it is the sense
that humans might be irrigating to
themselves the management the control
dominion over nature and climate that is
unacceptable is blasphemous and yet
practically speaking from all of the
objective evidence that we have we do
have that kind of control and you can't
manage a wilderness area in the United
States without worrying about invasive
species or really worrying about Santa
John's various parts of the heavily
visited water areas so an annual and
that's kind of a trivial example but
wilderness is supposed to be placed
where we we venture as guests and Leave
No Trace we've already left a trace
reflected everywhere and the oceans are
full of the plastic in the Sargasso Sea
so there's a lot that we have to clean
up on but we are responsible for the
earth and i think that the concept of
stewardship is a very biblical one it is
the way i am told by of Angelica's one
should talk about about nature and
nature conservation and protection I've
been was cautioned by size' cures ago
don't start talking about science that's
all those Darwin guys we don't like them
well okay language is important as far
as being part of nature I mean of course
in the natural system of things were
part of nature that's indisputable the
more we've known about DNA and the
origins of the species and the kind of
an auto that we share with nature with
other being sentient beings really some
of them seeming more and more I don't
think you can dispute that so I guess
I'd like to have that one both ways
all right well political right yes for
me EPA director Bill O'Reilly thank you
so much for joining us today for this
seminar and thank you all for joining us
as well